Chud Logic is like a terminally person who can barely even hold
a thousand concurrent viewers who spends half his stream seething
that the chat wants him to cover the Ethan Klein drama that he's
too big to cover himself so he can cover 80 hours of the newest
transve investigation on somebody's hairline. This guy can't
even make like decent content now and he's holding it against
me personally.
I'm like more interested in the Doryo stuff to be honest with
you. Now he's watching this section. Yeah. Let's just go to the
uh the Nick thing. Okay. Cuz I do feel like we're going to see
him go off. No. By the way, totally blind going into this. I
just got told that he was doing it. That he did this tonight.
I just saw the message about this. Okay.
>> So, it starts off with this willy bit >> Weird
how people acted with even though it was some of the least substantial
accusations we've seen. And Nick Dioro replies, "It's 11 and
I'm starting to fear the great sweep has begun." Black a cat
replies to Willie Mack by saying, "So if two women accuse Hassan
of sexual misconduct as well as extremely embarrassing personal
Oh, I feel like Do you think Nick is going to respond to this?
Do you think Nick is going to say, "Yeah, I'd wait." Do you think
Do you think Dioro will say, "Yeah, I'd wait here." Or do you
think he's going to respond at all? H I think he'd say something
like, "Well, if there was really just no evidence at all, then
I don't think I'd expect anyone to respond." Or something like
that when the evidence was this bad. >> Life details. You
and Nick will not cover it at all, even if he says
I somehow doubt that. And Willie replies, "You've said the same
stupid comment before." Assan has had brothel ali.
I'm starting to think if this turkey tom fellow was one of them
hefty balding. Okay. He immediately goes into a chud logic bid,
I guess. All right.
All right. I didn't think I listen. I thought he'd just, you
know, not show that Chud dominates all thoughts in his mind while
on vac. It's particularly egregious
because Chud's been gone on vacation for like three days now.
Four days,
right? Like it's explicitly like quite egregious,
>> Deep voiced trans fellas. I think these guys might have
flown home to cover it on the weekend, mate. I'm just saying.
I'm just saying, mate. If he if he was one of them hefty transes,
I think he would have been covering that tonight.
>> I recommend watching Nicholas Borio's latest video.
I never covered it. Keep coping.
>> Keep making up hypotheticals. [laughter] Doesn't change
reality. And black hat says to even compare two women directly
accusing with tech. >> So it's like something he could
respond to on the screen. I hope he's not seething too much about
Chud logic. >> Everything versus Hassan going to a random
brothel ability. >> I don't know if you saw it. I put it
at the VOD at the end. I don't know. I'm not going to sit here
and keep grinding Chud into the dirt. this probably the last
time that I address him. Um, but I put it at the end of the last
VOD to give context to why I was like ranting about it cuz there
are people who probably genuinely don't follow any of this. So,
I said that basically Chud uh the story came out between like
6:00 and 10:00 p.m. the night before and then by 8:00 in the
morning, Chud had already announced that like the great sweep
has begun. And by watching this, it is increasingly obvious this
is like a direct shot at me. At best, you can call it a direct
shot at me and Auggie. And then the next day, he adapts this
take to be about everybody else. And he's like, "Oi, I'm listening.
I'm talking about sensitive society, mate. You're just being
sensitive. Just listen. It's obviously a shot at me. Uh, this
is obviously a a knife to the back immediately after my friend
got accused of being like a
>> a knife to the back. Okay, that seems >> This
is a new form for me. But I will not have
people like Bo Blacks and Tipster get spoken about for year for
like a year. >> Now this part you could argue it's about
the chatters who are coming in one guying him saying it's a nothing
burger. You can do that >> and then it's nothing to see
here for
and it's nothing to see here for this. Now I've not looked at
this yet but I've got a feeling that the sweepers are going to
be in on this one. Okay.
And I'm not [__] >> I mean this is just a dog
whistle. We got like stormed for two weeks. This was like the
immediate uh trend sign. >> This is a dog whistle.
What do you mean it?
This one's a dog.
This is a dog whistle.
Uh he's saying that I don't I mean I feel like he's just saying
I don't want to hear from people saying this is nothing. Like
[__] off. I'm covering this. Get the [__]
out of here. If you're here to say it's nothing, get the [__]
out of here. Nobody cares. better >> suffering that gladly
that Bo Black is worth talking about for a year, but Turkey Tom's
embarrassing revelations
are a nothing burger. Okay,
by the way, literally just says embarrassing
and a lot of the humiliating stuff not debunked. Okay,
and I don't think that that's that makes Tom an awful person.
the fact that like yeah any of the stuff that was just embarrassing
alone none of that makes Tom a bad person right
but it is stuff that people would cover they do cover embarrassing
things about people that are adjacent to them that's just facts
>> that is absurd dude that is obvious insane obviously
insane bro >> by the way it's totally normal if the entire
allegation was just turkey Tom for me not to cover it that's
actually like a normal thing to not cover when your friend friend
gets exposed for embarrassing details the part that makes have
to cover it is the fact that like a person that I'm working with
is being implicated in like crimes. That's the only reason I
ever covered it on my channel. And if you're saying that you're
too bi You literally don't have to cover it in either case to
be honest with you.
Like I think you could have just had a response. I I don't believe
basically
I think he got pressured by his audience into covering it and
he blames Chud.
And I don't think he had he could have not covered it. He could
have said, "Hey, I'm really close to this. I'm not gonna I'm
basically not going to like cover anything here until Tom responds
because and if he doesn't respond, I'll cut professional ties
and if he does respond, he's responds tangibly. Then maybe we
could have a discussion after that. That would have been totally
fine. And maybe people would have been mad at him. Maybe even
Chud or Chud's viewers would have been mad at him. But realistically,
there would have been nothing wrong with that. All you had to
do is stand up business. Just don't be a weak willed little [__]
Stand up business. You're totally fine.
There's no there is no problem with that. Like he says, he just
didn't do it. >> Biased to sit there and laugh at your
friend while they're like leaking degenerate messages. That's
totally fine because I absolutely would be way too biased to
By the way, nothing Tom Nothing that got leaked about Tom from
Tom's own words was degenerate by the way. Like essentially nothing.
The fact that he DM' that age player is probably the most degenerate
thing. But you don't get him like he obviously is texting for
an audience there. There's not even anything that embarrassing
in terms of what Tom said. that and I never would
>> unless there's like an additional piece of information
there that makes me want to cover it. >> The day of the
diaper is here.
Basically, I woke up in the middle of the night cuz I fell asleep
early and it was just as this stuff was dropping. If this is
nothing to worry about, nothing to be concerned about. Okay.
Why is the podcast going on hiatus? So, I put the podcast on
hiatus when it was very clear that I was streaming the entire
time and didn't have an opportunity to even look into the allegations.
Like, I was live during this entire time slot. >> Yeah.
I don't I actually don't know why he did that. I That was That
was totally I have no idea why he did that. That was so stupid.
He ends his thing with like obviously Halfbaked's going to be
going on hiatus and then he maintains it after looking into the
stuff. Yes, they made him look so much worse. that his friend,
his like close friend is going to immediately pause ties with
him before like and by the way, most people didn't even realize
that it was that day. A ton of people were like, "Oh, it was
announced on Twitter. They're like, oh, you're like you've gone
through it and you're going to cut ties with this guy right now
until he responds in some way." Like when Muda can his podcast
with Knucks while talking to Chud. Yeah, I don't understand.
These people get so
I don't know. These people get so somehow it's very weird. Uh,
yeah, I heard about this, Maxi. Yeah, thank you. >> So,
there's no way I could have sat and read through like what was
it like 50 pages of Kiwi Farms, whatever the that happened in
that first night, and then Chud's like, "This tells you all you
need to know." I mean,
cool. And it was just as this stuff was dropping. If this is
nothing to worry about, nothing to be concerned about. Okay?
Why is the podcast going on haters? Okay, now listen. I will
be fair. I know what people in chat are thinking and are going
to say, okay, but my concern, >> dude, I will be fair,
goes on for like the least [__] charitable take I've
ever heard in my entire life. >> Ladies and gentlemen,
is the big sweep might be on. >> Literally 8:00 a.m. the
next morning, the big sweep is on, guys. The big >> But
my concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the big sweep might be on.
Okay, the mid the big sweep might be on. Okay, I am not participating
in the big sweep. Okay, this is a totally legitimate story to
cover and talk about and that's the end of it, bro. And if anyone
disagrees, if anyone thinks I'm doing >> He did say my
a culp, bro. >> Doing something wrong. >> The big
sweep is on, guys. The big >> But my concern, ladies and
gentlemen, is the big sweep might be on. Okay, the mid the big
sweep might be on. Okay, I am not participating in the big sweep.
Okay, this is a totally legitimate story to cover and talk about.
And that's the end of it, bro. And if anyone disagrees, if anyone
thinks I'm doing >> He did say my a cult, bro. >> Something
wrong.
But also,
is he not talking to the audience? He's saying this is a completely
legitimate story to cover. Has Nick said anything about it not
being a legitimate story to cover? Has Nick given any indication
of that? I
It seems like he's his audience. He does this all the time, right?
Like he does this with his audience all the time.
>> We'll talk about it. Okay, happy to talk about it, but
there is lit. >> I love this. I love this. I'm going to
implicate that you're sweeping and uh yeah, so I'm going to like
break you in the ass on this one and if you want to come on my
stream, I can actually profit off of you, too. It's like super
cool. It's like such a cool thing that he does. Hey, I'm going
to come in and I'm going to go you in the ass and then I'm going
to give you the courtesy of Nick.
By the way, Nick has described being in the by Chud Logic like
10 different times in the past two days. I don't understand why
he keeps saying Chud Logic him in the ass. Very weird, but he
just keeps saying it over and over again. Letting you come on
my show. Wow.
>> Nothing wrong with speaking about this and talking about
this. This is completely legitimate. And obviously
if Turkey Tom >> more than just a finger this time, okay,
Nick, that finger awoke something in Nick. Okay, he's thinking
about this a lot now. >> Makes videos using Kiwi Farms
as a source. Okay. Is totally legitimate of >> I added
this part in just for transparency. I don't think it m I don't
think anybody was saying that you can't cover it because Tom
uses Kiwi Farms and you can or whatever. I don't think that's
sort of relevant to this at all.
>> Well, that would be the response. By the way, Nick keeps
Nick keeps saying all these things. He's like, "This is about
me." And so when Chud keeps saying these things that I never
said, it's still about me. I didn't say this. Ch's so out of
his mind. It's like, well, wait, what?
No, he's probably talking about somebody who did say that.
I'm guessing that if you go back and look at the chat, there
would be a chatter who is saying, oh, this is just Kiwi Farms
rumors. Why would you cover it?
>> Make comments about it. >> It's hard to be British.
True. >> Question, bro. Okay. Now, >> now he gets
back into it here. >> I don't think Listen, guys. Okay,
listen. Okay.
I do not believe that people have got an obligation to cover
anything. People can cover what they want. Okay. But my question
would be, what would the coverage be like if this was about Idubbbz?
If it was revealed that Idubbbz that that Ana was into age play
and like that, what would the cover >> I would hanker down
and I would slander them. I would slander the out of them. I
would operate off of zero information. Also, yes, 100%. Ana Jooha
and uh the audience would be there immediately there's an audience
there for anything on these people no matter what
right that same audience that is like why would you cover this
it's nothing would say oh cover that yeah yeah oh my god what
did Ana Ana like made a face when Idub said something oh my god
he's like a and my friend of seven years are completely interchangeable
you could sub them in one for one without affecting that at all
whatsoever dude oh my god guys this is a crazy tag I'm actually
partial to my friend of seven years and I'm like openly telling
you this and it's like totally fine dreamed about this last night
and after watching Nick's stream I'm kind of black pill >> what's
the win what's the win condition there wow you're biased towards
your friend it's like well I now I know why you don't have any
friends from when you >> be and I think the >> guy
with no friends is surprised that people are biased towards their
friends >> answer to that tells you everything that you
need to >> wait you can be biased towards your friends
that's totally fine
right I actually I think
Uh, this is why I don't know if Chud is going after these guys
directly,
right? Or or like Nick directly.
I don't understand the slot tubers not covering it. I understand
Nick not covering it personally. I don't understand like a sensitive
society or a like a more Pegasus some of these people. I don't
understand them not covering it or covering it badly.
That's to me that's all that matters, right? And yeah, I'm trying
to think.
I don't think he I don't think he has to cover it for one thing.
And then for another thing, where else would you go with this?
Oh, I had another point here. He doesn't necessarily have to
cover it. And you could just say as much. I don't know. I I had
like another point here and I totally lost it. I totally lost
my train of thought. But it's fine.
It doesn't have to cover it in my opinion. But I I really think
this is about the audiences and what the audiences want, right?
Like cuz Chud was really annoyed about getting constantly pressured
to cover the uh the Ethan and Assan the H3 drama, right? He got
really annoyed about that and now it's like after all this time
there's drama involving somebody else and then those same people
who are like wait are you going to cover the latest are you going
to cover Ana like saying something weird in Idubbbz's presence
for the thousandth time and Chud's like no. And then some stuff
drops at Turkey Tom that like seems juicy, seems like really
like massive drama.
And
what? Like this is a nothing burger. Don't cover it. Isn't it
weird that you're covering it? I If he's talking about the audience
largely andor the slot tubers, the people who would pick this
kind of stuff up. I makes total sense to me. Makes less sense
to me for Nick.
I'm sure he was going after Nick in some way, right? He probably
had Nick in mind here somewhat.
But I think it's a even if he was totally thinking about Nick,
if he was totally thinking about Nick would be wrong. I think
even if he's thinking about Nick a little bit rather it's mostly
about the audience. Seems like it. And I think the answer to
that tells you everything that you need to know. Does fridge
be? And I think the answer >> guy with no friends is surprised
that people are biased towards their friends. >> Answer
to that tells you everything that you need to know, doesn't it?
And I think the answer >> Okay. The answer to how would
they react in this way? >> Answer to that tells you everything
that you need to know, doesn't it? And I think the answer to
that tells you everything that you need to know, doesn't it?
[laughter] But to >> Dude, Nick is Nick is getting like
personal with his own editing about Chud,
isn't he? You notice that? That's him taking the time to add
that to one of his videos at the end. [laughter] Like he's actually
that angry about Chud that he's like going to go and custom edit
the end video for the to go and be like this guy. Yeah, you Chud
to me. >> Very funny. Very very funny. Look at who decides
to talk about this and who
>> This is 100%. This this claim right now is 100% about
me. >> And that will give you an indication
of what the deal is. Okay. That's going to tell you everything
you need to know. >> All right. I'm taking a look at your
channel right now and it appears it's it's past 8:00 a.m. Not
really seeing your video here. Are you seeing a stream or a video
from Mr. Chudlo Logic? Final stream before I'm away. H seems
like he ran. Here's the thing. Now, this is a couple of days
later. In between, he posted this tweet, and this tweet is the
exact same verbatim argument from the clip, only now it's an
allencompassing
>> Wait, wait, wait,
hold on, hold on.
Is Nick just being like intentionally is he just like openly
lying here?
Is he just like obviously openly lying?
That seems weird to do. Does he think Does he think people do
that about him? Does he think Chud does that about him?
Right? Because Nick knows for a fact that Chud's on vacation.
I'm sure he knows for a fact that Chud said Chud literally said,
"When this updates, I will be on vacation. I won't get a chance
to cover this anymore. If there's a response, I'll cover it when
I get back, but I'm going on vacation."
He knows Chud's on vacation, right? I Well, I don't think they
timed it. No, no, no, no. I don't think they timed it,
I don't think they timed it at all.
I just think that like Chud said he was going to be gone, that
he he'd respond when he gets back.
It's I I don't I don't necessarily agree that they timed it.
I I like laugh about a joke about it,
but
just in terms of like Nick seething here overall,
I don't know, man. It just seems it seems really inappropriate.
And now he's just like lying about this. Oh, he's sweeping. I
guess he's gone. Well, I guess he ran. Oh my god. >> Right.
Why? >> Only 21K views after 12 hours. Looks like my humble
video going over the first part of the Turkey Tom allegations
is the most viewed on the topic, which is seemingly a product
of no large commentary channels picking up the story yet. I have
never believed that people have an Okay, this is the part that's
literally out of the thing where he's talking about me. Uh, I
have never believed that people have an obligation to cover a
story. People can talk about what they want. That being said,
it seems insane to me that if Assan or Idubbbz had this exact
same thing happen to them, we would already have 20 videos from
the daily slop channels. So, he's adapting the take to cover
more things and then he gets into a call with Auggie and he's
like, "I have no idea what you're talking about, bro. I wasn't
calling you guys out." Aic, final stream before I'm aware. >> I
think he eventually conceds to this to be clear. >> Wait.
H seems like he ran. >> Here's the thing. When you called
us out for sweeping, this was like >> Wait, wait, wait,
hold on, hold on. 6 hours before the >> Wait, when you
say us, okay, because people are very much >> me and Nick.
[laughter] >> Okay, that's because you guys are very sensitive
about getting called sweepers. Okay, I'm >> This is complete
co >> I'm talking broadly. All right, and you're looking
at it and it's like a raw shark test. I'm saying no big commentary
channels picked this up and you're sat there going, "He's talking
about me and only me." And it's like, bro, I'm talking about
it broadly. It's not bro. is such you might have been the tweet.
>> There might have been 20%. Yeah. Yeah. I'm pulling up
your tweet right now. Go over the tweet.
There might have been like 20%. Yeah. Yeah. I'm pulling it up
right now. There might have been like 20% where you were talking
about like a cheeto or guys nobody gives a about. But it's clear
when you're calling out sweeping these people
call out me and Nick for sweeping
about sweeping and you complain about your so
no. Stand on business. Stand on. You're so sensitive to us. Sweeper.
>> You wanted You were first the story. You wanted to call
us out. >> I said in the next stream I spoken to both of
you and you both might talk about it. >> Wait, next stream?
Oh, then what about the first stream? What happened in the first
stream? >> You're just sensitive to getting called a sweeper.
That tweet came about cuz I looked on YouTube and no multi 100,000
sub channel. >> Yeah, cuz the story had come out like 3
hours. Yeah, but you kind of already took Nick. Would you have
respected it more if he just came out and said, "Yeah, I was
talking about you and Auggie, but I was trolling." He's not trolling.
This is exact. This is actually how he feels 100%. Chud Logic
is like a terminally person who can barely even hold a thousand
concurrent viewers who spends half his stream seething that the
chat wants him to cover the Ethan Klein drama that he's too big
to cover himself so he can cover 80 hours of the newest transve
investigation on somebody's hairline. This guy can't even make
like decent content now and he's holding it against me personally.
>> Took your shot at me before that. You took your shot
at 8 a.m. the next morning on me
>> EHD was definitely exhausting for a year, but this bridge
burning is baffling.
[laughter] >> So you go live in the morning and you The
problem is that Chudlo Logic had an issue with the content that
I was covering over the course of a calendar year, but he's probably
too much of a to say anything. Not because he wanted to stay
friends with me, but because he's worried that the shared audience
that I lent him would leave. That's probably the God's honest
truth of the matter.
Oh. Oh [__] >> Use a Nick soundboard. Okay.
Oh my god. So Chud was too scared to say that he was no longer
he didn't like Nicholas anymore because he was worried about
losing the audience that Nick lent him. Interesting. [clears throat]
Interesting. Interesting.
Um,
man, I don't know. I don't know how true that is. Maybe
I am I remembering. So, to my memory,
was Nick like a,200-500
viewer streamer when
like before the the Hassan versus Ethan stuff really kicked off?
I thought I thought like a,000 to,500 was about his range. Am
I crazy on that?
I thought he bounced up massively
when he started hardcore taking the side of Ethan in those in
those uh confrontations, right? Bring up the stats. I can't do
stats cuz he's on YouTube. He was around 2K or so. Okay, 2K.
So, he like doubled up. All right. I thought he was around the
same size as Chut, more or less, but apparently he's a little
bigger. You can stats. Sure. Give me the stats. Wherever you
got them, Vin, there's a site. Sure. Show me where the free stats
are for live streams and I'll pull them up
because I know I know his stats right now are like 5,000 viewers,
but I don't have a site that will give me the other stats that
we're looking for.
Okay, I don't have a site that'll give me the other stats we're
looking for. Um,
so it's just weird to me that when they're about the same size
that he would say that. And I think I think two things happened
for Nick. I think Nick also Tom was building an audience and
then Tom just stepped down. and he was like, "I don't want to
stream anymore." Right? And then a I think a lot of those people
ended up going to watch Nick as well, right? Am I crazy? So,
I think Tom quitting also helped. So, there was Tom quitting
and there's the Ethan stuff. And Nick did like double or even
close to triples the size of his audience. He He pulled in a
whole bunch more people.
I don't think this is on SocialBlade. I So, I think he pulled
in way more people. I just think when
when Chud was like originally not covering this stuff, I don't
think there was like a huge audience there. I don't think people
were really that concerned. Some people were probably asking
him about it, but I don't think there's like a massive Dioro
audience there that just would leave and he would be too scared
to criticize. I I think he just didn't want to burn that bridge
cuz he didn't want to burn that bridge. Like the the connection
to Nick and like fixing that would be advantageous to everybody,
right?
But I think
and maybe this is true to some extent. I do think that there's
something to Nick saying like, "Well, I don't want to hang out
with these people because
like they're going to criticize me and make me look worse and
that actually [__] with my money." I think that's
obviously
for better or worse, right?
Like if you if you do things that are worthy of criticism and
people can specify these criticisms and you feel like it's difficult
to respond to them and then you constantly hang around them and
they're they're going to make those same criticisms, that's probably
going to with his money. That's probably true,
Tom quit streaming because because of that weirdo chick, the
Bel Deline wannabe got hacked and his fix were out there in the
ether. I thought he quit streaming before that. I thought he
quit streaming around the Destiny time and that was like a month
after the Destiny stuff, wasn't it?
I thought it was like a month after.
I thought he quit basically at the Destiny stuff. Anyway,
that tactic fails longterm though, IMO.
Um, no it doesn't. Why would it fail? Why would it fail longterm?
Poop my pants off.
I think
I think it doesn't necessarily fail longterm at all. I think
Ethan Klein is like that actually, almost entirely. And I think
he's built a very long career out of that. I don't see why you'd
think that fails eventually. I don't think it does. Yeah. And
I think um Oh man, how do I put it? I think it's like a good
money decision. I just think it wasn't who Nick was before this.
Like Nick was very he was going in the opposite direction entirely.
And I wish I had a good read on how he was when I first met him
because I would have just handled conversations with him very
differently
in a personal like
Um I didn't realize that was the direction he was going in.
There's just like a certain way that you could be charitable
to somebody that you shouldn't be if they're in this mode. You
know what I mean?
Anyway, um we can keep going, but I I don't think that's necessarily
wrong if he just wants to keep his money up, >> but he's
probably too much of a to say anything. Not because he wanted
to stay friends with me, but because he's worried that the shared
audience that I lent him would leave. That's probably the God's
honest truth of the matter for the first >> That's probably
the issue. The issue is that Nick Dioro doesn't want to talk
to people. Nick Dioro doesn't want to come onto my stream after
I slandered him to give me free content. Nick Dioro doesn't do
this. But re the reality is he probably has wanted to call me
out for a really long time and he's worried about the community
overlap.
So that's my stance on chud logic.
>> Just answer the question if two women directly accuse
Hassan of
>> man. I just I I disagree. I think there are people in
Chud's audience who really hate Nick and I think that gets like
weird.
I get like the same thing with Quan where like there are people
in his audience who just really like there are times where I
think like man I don't know if there's like a bunch of people
in Quean's audience people he's like close to who do hate me
there probably is a point where you just don't want to be interacting
with like that group of people at all probably I don't know where
it is exactly
you just like kind of ignore them or something
um
I think it does it does like trickle down in a way that's difficult
to deal
half of them are joking. Well, hold on. But there are a lot of
people in Chud's audience that I know who aren't joking, who
actually really hate Nick and do have Chud's ear. And so that
can be awkward in the same way that it's really hard for let's
say like um
oh let's say I mean Nick with um >> with like Willie [clears throat]
and his friends, right? That gets really awkward
>> like Queenman or me. Like there are people who really
hate Queenman or me who are around Nick. That will get very awkward
very quickly, right?
Uh hold on. Latigious Gamer, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Really appreciate it, buddy. I should add more time to the thing
before it goes away. Get what? 25 subs and 12
of TTS. Okay. All right. All right. All right. Joe Mack is not
the same. Joe Mack is not somebody Quinn talks to. It's not the
same thing um at all. Yeah. Yeah, it's not remotely close. It's
like um I don't want to blame Stylo entirely, but I'd say Stylo
is like when you watch Stylo and Chud talk about Nick from a
couple weeks ago and you watch you watch Stylo who Chud is close
to. I think you watch Stylo come in and talk about how much he
hates Nick. Like he has a sthing hatred for Nick. And then I
thinkW's got quite a solid dislike for Nick as well. I don't
know how much they chat. They might not chat a ton in private,
but I do think there's some influence there.
I don't know. It's I'm trying to think if like BB Poison
like absolutely hated Quan and constantly him to me and constantly
him from the chat and all of this,
right? I wonder how that would look. I wonder how that would
It's just It's interesting,
right? Because then you start to second guess if this person
like, you know, if I argue with this person, they like try to
make me look bad. Is that because their friends have put them
up to that? I think you have to have a certain mindset to like
get around that.
If you're if you're somebody who like is very egotistical, who
is kind of like fragile in that way, that can really with you,
I think.
So strange how creators in their communities see each other.
Yeah, cuz like well let's just say you know Chud mocks Nick for
something and Nick's thinking like we're friends. You wouldn't
mock me for that if we're friends. They just have like a different
standard there. And then he wonders is that like the people who
hate
me and his community are like telling him to say this stuff and
then is he playing into that and making me look bad to my community
to try to shave off like audience from me? Well, it's not just
fragile
because probably in effect when Chud does that little like shot
at Nick, people might not want to admit this, that probably does
shave some audience off from Nick that they're like, "Oh, they
didn't really thought about that." And you know what? Nick really
does kind of hound this one thing. He kind of does suck Ethan
off, right?
that a natural part of friendship probably does actually plant
that seed in somebody's head to
like not let something like that go in an audience member's head
because the audience doesn't understand like the dynamic dynamic
you people would have in private at all. Right.
So, I don't know how Chud handles that or how but maybe I don't
know. I'm like talking through how I think of this at a high
level. I haven't really tried to put it together that much.
I don't think
Uh,
I I think it could. I think it could. There's like something
going on there where it could. Nick's audience. Yeah, but hold
on. Porter Beller, I'm saying that a lot of people would would
be like, you know, kind of picking a side at that point. I do
agree that a lot of Nick's new audience is there to watch him
suck off Ethan Klein specifically. Yeah. Yeah, I agree with
Anyway, I but I do think that like before that's clear to anyone
in whatever May of last year, like nine months ago, before that's
clear to anyone, Chud makes that joke. And that is a joke. And
I don't think Chud meant anything bad by it, right? Obviously,
but I can understand Nick's thoughts on how that like he's kind
of, you know, trying to make Nick look silly, make him look kind
of disingenuous,
how he could interpret that and grow it up in his own mind to
something that's like sinister.
And I don't know how to fix that. I I don't know how you like
fix that for Nick cuz again I I get the impression that it's
like pretty sincere from Chud that he doesn't want to or these
people or there's a chance that like Chud's way more a machavevelian
than I'm expecting
possibly. I don't know what if Chud really is doing that. What
if Chud really was trying to with these guys behind? I don't
know.
But I I haven't seen any evidence of it yet. We'll have to see.
I think if you're going to be streamer friends with Chud at this
point, you have to accept him mocking you in a cutting way. Yeah,
he's got to watch how he does it though cuz I've watched him
talk to people, smaller streamers a couple times. I'm fine cuz
I I don't know. Maybe it's I think it's me playing video games.
I like don't get tilted at people trying to me. But I know I
personally get tilted when I watch Chud talk to like a smaller
creator. And
sometimes it's like, bro, your ego is way too big. Like you're
not you're not that much bigger, okay?
You're like twice the size or maybe four or five times the size
as creator. You're not like on a different level of humanity,
which is what it comes off as sometimes. All right.
Little bit. Little bit.
But I think um I felt that way. I I said that criticism on my
stream and then the next time he talked to Dickers, which is
who he's talking to at that point, I think he kind of apologized
that he went a little too far. Just talking is fine, right? But
treating people like they're really small and like total
like total jokes. I do think that's weird. Brought on Henry Resilian
a lot when he was a nobody. Yeah, that's how I think Chud was
before and then I just watched him I've watched him speak a couple
times with people and I'm like dude talk but like I don't know
the channel size stuff just gets weird. It gets a little weird
that's all. But I think he probably agreed cuz I think he apologized
to Dickers the next time you talked to him.
Anyway, I don't even remember what that was responding to. Oh,
mocking at a cutting way. Sure, sure, sure. Think he actually
believes he won that debate with Pisco? I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know. I really don't. Very interesting.
Thinking about how that went. Um,
does he think he won? Really?
I don't know. Maybe. Hard to tell. I think he just wants to move
on from it.
>> Misconduct. Would Nick cover it before he responded?
What do you think? >> Nicholas Dioro dreamed about this
last night and after watching Nick's stream, I'm kind of blackpilled
on this. >> Who do you recommend for politics now? >> Complained
about oversaturation of EHD content, but he milked pirate software
until he couldn't. >> No, he he has his own topics that
he milks or whatever. But the problem is that if you watch any
Ethan Klein segment that he's doing, it's obvious that he hates
it. He absolutely hates that he has to cover it, but there was
nothing else to cover that day. and he resents people who do.
>> I really like you. >> Why would you? >> But
why is he so mad at you? I think I personally, again, I could
never prove this, but I think he just blames me for >> because
it's been like my channel's been doing fine and I think that
he's just like a petty.
>> Yes or no? Krispy replies to Willie Mac by saying, "Remember
when you accused?"
Hold on, man.
Blames him for what? For like the EHD content being bad. that
that wasn't anything.
What
I assume he means he blames me for like his channel stagnating
or something which like maybe that's true. Uh whe whether or
not that's fair to blame you for it or not could be true that
like you totally stepping away from that he had to rebuild kind
of around himself only whereas he had a lot of commentary people
on he was trying to talk to those people a lot during the day.
Right.
Could be. Could be.
Yeah. I think I think maybe it's the
or maybe he's just trying to say he resents him for growing.
I don't know.
You probably have to watch how you grow your channel on YouTube
because I think as you grow your channel on YouTube, if you grow
it in the wrong way, you get an audience that almost becomes
an anchor.
I've talked about this before, but from what I understand, the
way the algorithm works on YouTube is basically once some something's
doing good with your core audience, that's when it breaks the
seal and goes outside to other audiences. Excuse me. If you build
up an audience that doesn't want to see the kind of content you
do anymore or something along these lines, if you build up an
audience who is really interested in one thing and you pivot
really hard, that audience can be like an anchor where you'll
never break that that original seal to get like widespread
like love for a video. Like you're almost I think you might almost
be better off making a new channel at that point sometimes.
It's it's kind of tough, man. Queman and Auggie of doxing with
no evidence because your feelings got hurt. And Willie says,
"Crazy cuz I never did that." I said, "I was doxed by Queen's
unhinged viewers." And then I criticized Queen. All right, so
let's hop ahead here. Auggie RFC. My
>> I don't want to talk about this again. I don't want
to talk about this again. Bro, you are so It's just so gay. You
want to know where the real sweep is? The real Sweep for Your
Friends comes out is with the Willy Mack. It's so obvious, man.
Retweets a video that's total misinformation. Complete misinformation,
right? Leaves it up for days after being told it's misinformation.
Says he'll comment on it. And then goes live and says, "Oh, actually,
I can't comment on this. I just I told Willie not to talk about
this and he he's on his own." And you never you take the retweet
down after multiple days. You never address it at all. You never
say Williey's lying. You never call him out for it. the guy who
used to do all of this. You changed everything up about how you
operate to not give us a W on that to not just go, "Oh, yeah,
Willy's lying about these guys." It's so embarrassing, man. That's
when he's like, "Oh, you know, I guess I just won't I won't be
collaborating with anybody from commentary anymore. I guess I
just won't do that." Okay, whatever you say, dude. Whatever you
say, man. >> Is the strongest broom, many have said. >> RFC
then tweets out, "My broom is the strongest broom, many have
said." and then post I've been around way long enough to know
that 90% of E allegations are total scoring to are trying to
do as much damage as they can because they are angry, emotional,
and in some cases evil. Watching people figure this lesson out
for the 50th time as if it's the first time this has ever happened
has been ridiculously funny to watch.
>> Appreciated the shout out. >> Chud was always
a stirer. The leading and baiting questions he says always reminded
me of Edwin. >> Yeah, dude. I listen. Hey, I'm going to
sit here and make as many comments as possible, call you sensitive,
demand you come on my stream, then I get a free hour of me screaming,
"You're, bro. You're bro." Debate over. Wow, dude. So, that's
so cool. >> Nicholas [laughter] the goat. Thank you for
the five. >> Wow. I get to give you a free hour of content.
That's awesome, man. Did anybody watch that Auggie debate? It
was completely like it was impossible to watch. It's almost like
you should hear both sides out and make a decision once the cards
have been played instead of jumping in instantly like everyone
wanted me to do. In conclusion, I was right to wait. You were
all wrong. >> Chud, it's sad that he is clearly sniping
at you for months and is too cowardly to make a real pass at
you. >> Well, I'm sure he will now.
>> That is that is like the gayest fakest comment I've
ever seen. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Who is that? >> Right
to >> guy. Random 42.
that I can't see how that could possibly be true. I can't see
how that could possibly be true. Okay. Where what passive aggressive
sniping or something? What? Clearly sniping at you for months.
One time with a joke, man. Okay. All right. Whatever. Whatever.
>> I just I can't imagine somebody who's a Chud viewer
and then was like, "Oh, actually Chud's totally wrong on all
this stuff."
I can't see it. I really can't. Chud, it's sad that he is clearly
sniping at you for months and is too cowardly to make a real
pass at you. >> Well, I'm sure he will now. >> All
of you. Locos tweets out a screenshot of Turkey Tom's video and
captions it by saying, "No way. Turkey Tom's response to the
allegations is showing a bunch of messages where you can see
the main two girls against him literally begging for him." Low
tier God and Mis have wished they could do some like this. And
Nick Rommancer replies, "Honestly, the most entertaining drama
video I've watched." And loco sword says it's funny because there
are drama videos with less care and thought put into them than
this. And this is still one of the funniest just because the
comeback was >> All right. What other topics are in here?
Accusers react. I Oh, I want to see some of this. Yeah, cuz we
didn't cover all of it. >> She is watching the video about
the first 30 seconds of it and she says pack watch for Turkey
Tom. Night Tom, you can't hide and lie. Left for dead or Clorox.
Katie also made a post on Kiwi Farms where she replied, >> "I'm
going to kill him." Dude, that was that was so funny when we
cut to this immediately. It literally was just like, "Oh, so
what's going on with the thread right now?" [laughter] >> And
people were joking about this cuz her I guess her plane never
landed cuz she never did come back and say what >> The
other accuser also went to Kiwi Farms to make some post direct.
>> Yeah. You going to address the DMing miners? You come
on. You going to address the random [__] that I made
that I brought up last night? >> The camera out a lying.
I'm just gonna I want to see
I don't think he will. I thought I thought maybe there was a
chance a small chance that he'd look at the doxing stuff and
cover the the Augie combo that happened. I think there's a small
chance. Doesn't look like it though. Looks like he moves straight
past it. >> Piece of [__] She also then replied
to herself saying, "Also, I wasn't bleeding because of my period
and you know damn well. I told you I liked it because >> now
I kind of want to watch the Twitter versus stuff and see did
how did he cover this?" Hold on. Twitter versus
or internet sorry internet versus internet versus should call
it internet versus
we go through the Willy Mac stuff. It gets on to crispy legs
>> replies to Will saying remember when you accused Queman
and Auggie of doxing with no evidence because your feelings got
hurt and Willie says crazy cuz I never did that. I said I was
doxed by Queen's unhinged viewers and then I criticized Queman
for giving a hypothetical where I deserved it. You guys just
make up stuff. I've offered to talk to Auggie and show him behind
the scenes. >> You know that Nick, like reading this was
immediately like, wait, if you said his audience did it, you're
accusing him of being complicit, right? That's the obvious implication.
By the way, I do believe he basically says it's his fault. Like
Queen's fault. >> He's confused at all. And Krispy replies,
"Yes, you accuse them with no evidence." Augie, you should let
Willie show you his secret. This is why I accuse you files. Mesa
replies to Willie by saying, "You did say it's not normal for
Jaw/ Queen's community to have this much doxing coming from it.
The victims are Destiny, Dan, me, Hutch with no evidence. If
you're accusing, >> by the way, he says just look at the
Kiwi Farms thread. I think the only person from that thread who
is doxed by
But that could even conceivably, sorry, be doxed by someone from
my audience like like basically I assume if you're not brain
dead, that you would understand
that when I was, you know, friends with Destiny, when I was close
to Destiny, obviously people who were docs during that time,
that's not on me. That couldn't possibly be blamed on me,
And then after that,
the only person who was doxed was like Willie. There was like
Willie and then I think Stale
who has his YouTube video or his YouTube channel name as his
literal name. I think him as well, but like it was a it was using
his name and searching his name on like LinkedIn or something.
I think those are the two.
>> You are by extension accusing them as well. You're just
lying. And Willie replies, I'm not gonna post all of those people's
doxes. Go to Kooie Farms and look it up. Then look up. >> Yeah,
he got he got on this one. He got walked so hard on this one.
>> Destiny was just like, "Look, look at like look look
guys look." He told Hutch and Willie, "Hey guys, look. Um, look,
you got doxed in this thread." And it's because of these guys
when both of those people, sorry, Willie was doxed by someone
anonymous.
Hutch was docked way before any of this stuff leaked
like months ago. It was part of the progressive stuff. >> Just
watch the stream where Hutch says it. And Queenman replies, "Those
accounts is a nice use of a plural to dodge the fact you've got
no evidence for the person who actually did it. You don't trick
anyone when you do this, Willie. It just shows us all what an
inbred low IQ go dog you are." Destiny quotes Willie's original
post with a long LOL with a deep breath in the middle. And Willie
replies, "You did respond. I also talked to you twice. Just cuz
your response sucks, it doesn't make my statement any less true.
AR RFC then tweets out, my broom is the strongest broom, many
have said and then post, I've been around. >> Okay, I just
wanted to see if there was anything else hitting me in the face.
>> The funny part is that after this she claims she hadn't
seen the video yet, so she's just gunning whatever's in the in
the uh the >> All right, from there I do think I wanted
to see if Nick was going to talk through what these posts again.
According to her, we all deserve to get nuked and she was actively
looking for information on her. I find it absolutely hilarious
that she was the only one to end up getting blasted and nobody
convince me can convince me why that isn't funny.
I mean, you say that I the unfortunate thing here's the other
thing about, you know, going after people like this.
I feel like you people don't understand. You just give pe like
a whole bunch of reason for that person to keep looking up for
information on you guys forever and then if she posts it.
I don't understand how you can be mad about that. You know what
I'm saying? Like basically all of these guys
are celebrating this for this direct thing happening that that
like this woman got doxed and their friend didn't get doxed or
whatever. But now if she were to find that information and publish
it,
right? I Where's your leg to stand on? Does that even exist anymore
>> to the doxing thing and like calling me a liar? We're
just pivoting because they were mad that Tom got out of it >> by
Sacramento about the whole situation. It starts by Copen screenshotting
this post by Y golonic and saying apparently
it's extreme BPD in a Sacramento saying yeah I overblue some
[__] like I said I gave into it and told him I liked
it should have been more 100 about that but I will say I didn't
lie about >> I mean this is where it ended like this moment
was where it was completely done >> then doing whip hits
Katie brought it up first and those texts were real hence why
he docks me and yeah a response is coming at this point it's
all out there so whatever man Ralph male is ugly as whoever he
is >> dude Ethan Ralph catching a crazy stray right here.
>> Ethan Ralph a quote tweets, [laughter] >> bro.
This is No way. >> Didn't see this post by saying Wait,
I didn't see this, dude. [clears throat] I didn't I didn't see
this.
Ethan >> This already wants the alpha male. I woke up to
39 DMs and they all said that Ethan Ralph could tame this wild.
>> This already wants the Ralpha male. I woke up to 39.
I'm just [clears throat] curious for all the people out here
who are like super Oh my god, it's doxing. Oh my god, it's doxing.
Uh, why do you guys hang out with Salvo? I mean, that was just
my question. I don't know. That's I'm just wonder why do you
hang out with Salvo?
>> Whatever.
Where
what where
do we wait?
Doro guidelines. No doxing. This policy will be enforced harshly.
>> Okay. and they all said only Ethan Ralph could tame
this wild. Also, whip it. Um, are we in the eighth grade, you
silly [__] Copen then also screenshots a longer response
that Sacramento made with the caption, Sacramento has posted
a short essay response on KF as she and Left 4 Dead continue
their world record attempt for victim to lock out any present
speedrun. And it's Sacramento saying, "I understand people have
rightfully called me out for saying stuff about Tom without providing
the full context and spinning the narrative about certain things.
I'm sorry for not providing the full cont
the goat. >> I actually haven't read this one of the situation.
Here is the full truth with no lies. Just 100% coming clean.
Yes, we were both into King's stuff, but I will say he did never
ask before engaging in it. So, I just assumed he was into that
and played into it from after our first encounter. On our first
>> I'm sorry. I just don't believe that she wasn't into
any kinks and is like a vanilla.
I just don't believe it >> encounter. He was very Why don't
you believe it? is cuz she says, "Yes, we were both into kinky
stuff." >> What? Why did he just say this in >> Context
and spinning the narrative about certain things. I'm sorry for
not providing the full cont.
>> I actually haven't read this first. >> I'm sorry.
I just don't believe that she wasn't into any kinks and is like
a >> He paused right before it. Okay. >> Encounter.
He was very rough and engaged in choking and BDSM without asking.
>> Oh, no. Hold on. It was right after. Yes, we were both
into kinky stuff, but I will say he did never ask before engaging
in it. So, I just assumed he was into that and played into it
from after our first encounter on our first >> I'm sorry.
I just don't believe that she wasn't into any kinks and is like
a >> Are we catching that? Yes, we were both into kinky
stuff. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I don't believe this stupid
is just like not into kinks at all. That she's like she she's
totally vanilla. Well, it's cuz she literally is in the video.
You're responding to that sentence right now. Like right there,
you're responding to the sentence where she says, "Yes, we were
both into kinky stuff." He did never ask before engaging in it,
so I just assumed he was into that and played into it.
>> her. I just don't believe it. It's >> a encounter.
He was very rough and engaged in choking and BDSM without asking
before. What he was into was basically play/ CNC. >> Hey
guys, I know I lied about 98% of my allegations, but now I'm
going to tell you the truth. Again, it doesn't hit like none
of this matters to me. So that's why I repeat. >> Wait,
this hold on.
I don't think I don't think Tom had a response for this except
that in DMs he would correct her to say consensual times or whatever,
right?
I think there's a reason she was referring to it that way and
you lean towards something that is verging on some kind of play
CNC type of thing that he's talked about with a lot of other
people that he's clearly into that I don't think he's ever denied
being into at all. Right. Like he's never once denied being into
this kind of thing. That's clearly the thing they're talking
>> Repeatedly referred to it as such. That wasn't out of
the blue me calling our encounters a >> I like I understand
that Tom basically would say
consensual times or something like that, right? But she felt
it was like he was there's obviously something there where he
was saying
he did. No, the only thing is is the same DMs we saw where he
corrects, right? She says like I'm ready for times or something
and he's like you mean consensual times or something like this
right? Like that's basically the back and forth they had whenever
she would call it play. He would say no no consensual.
It's like well she's calling it play for a reason obviously right?
Like there was clearly something going on there
and we know from other stuff like the Kai document. Kai literally
lays out that Tom's super into that stuff. Right. >> Right.
Obviously I never asked him to be especially aggressive at first.
It was like that from the jump. It was because of the nature
of our encounters. I assumed that was what he was into. Yes,
I'm into some freaky [__] like that, but he is very
much into it, too. And that doesn't mean that he occasionally
didn't take it too far to the point where I would express physical
pain. Tom was only able to ejaculate from the videos or if I
was crying in pain, and that is the truth. Also, it's true I
had never used KF before my relationship with Tom and he was
on the website often and did have issues with ED. Also, yes,
I used to be online and I knew who Tom was, but my online activity
has been very limited in the past few years and all of my accounts
were private. The bleeding was caused by not my birth control.
I made >> Oh, I didn't even read this original Sacramento
response. This we're getting it through Nicholas's eyes. I didn't
even actually go through this. This must have just been earlier
today, right? Bro, you can't talk about the birth control making
you bleed for a month. Not include that at any point during the
entire thing and go, "No, it was still the though. Yeah, I lied
about not having any medical conditions. I lied about bleeding
for a month at a time, but you have to believe me. I was telling
the truth about this." Sure to note that in my text with him,
I said I was on my period sometimes or just bleeding after sex.
If you review the screenshots we have both posted, I would be
on my period off and on for a month on occasion, but I would
bleed consistently after sexual interaction. You also asked him
to bloody his sword. >> Nicholas the
>> Oh, sorry. Nick is saying Nick read the line saying
currently that they were both into kink stuff or both into kinky
stuff. And then Well, I think she said she implied she was innocent.
Like she hadn't had that many relationships, right?
That's that's what she said. She said, "I I haven't had that
many relationships, so I wasn't I wasn't sure whatever." She
said something that implied innocence, but then she says, "Sure,
we're both into kink stuff." And Nick says, "To this moment,
I don't even believe that she wasn't into kink at all." Right,
>> goat, thank you for the $5. >> Yeah, before mass,
dude. >> Dude, you got to get some before mass. >> And
then you ask for [laughter] then you ask for forgiveness >> on
my periods >> during confession.
>> I confess I went to mass to get some, but he would also
cause me to bleed multiple times from our encounters when I wasn't.
There is a clear difference between period blood and blood from
being wounded, TMI. Also, the Lolita poster was in my best friend's
room, and I was calling her room goals because I thought her
squishallows are cute. Tom has been in my room [laughter] multiple
times, and I did not have any Lolita or related stuff in my room.
So, I think it's odd he referenced that, especially >> I
think it's odd that you said that you didn't have any like reaction
or interaction with like Hello Kitty and then it found out that
like actually was Yeah, that was you. Yeah, you completely lied
about the Hello Kitty thing to like smear to like aing Ellie's
room is filled to the brim. >> So, I don't believe you
here either >> with figures, >> dude. I don't. She
lied a lot. That is another like explicit lie saying she wasn't
into that stuff, but she was excited when her friend gave her
the gift or whatever. Her friend was like she was like, "Oh yeah,
he got me this stuff. It's so cool." Right. And then what else
was there? And then she had the the Pearler bead. >> I
don't have a Lolita poster. I also don't have any I don't have
any uh Hello Kitty merchandise. I don't know where this is coming
from. I have no knowledge of any of this. This is so bizarre.
>> And he visited her IRL. One thing he did not address
is the fact that he >> I mean that's really convenient.
>> He did hit me in the face multiple times which I never
asked for nor consent to do. He also did not address Katie being
bruised from their encounters which she proved with photographic
evidence. >> Yeah, the small things she lied about make
it even more of like a compelling
>> A few months ago, Ched cracked his head open at a pub.
Maybe he got brain
>> The text with my roommates were genuine and I did tell
her about a time after we had that was very >> I've heard
this theory many times. Not many dispute it to be honest. >> Pretty
aggressive. >> Nick, I know you're fighting with Chud,
but you need to make up with him for Dude, there's literally
this is probably the last time I ever speak about him in any
capacity. >> And he did say he >> to him about him
in general. This is it. I hope you enjoyed the commentary. Civil
>> He liked hurting me. I was uncomfortable after that
one experience, but I still >> I'm going to go make content.
>> Stayed with it and fed into it. Tom did bring up the
Liam and Kai situation with me multiple times and I knew nothing
about the details of that. I don't know if you do that. I don't
know.
I think
I think Ana and Idubbbz did the same thing
and that sort of blew up on them, right? Like totally ignoring
criticism. Well, maybe not Ana. Ana didn't feel like Idubbbz
was for a long time basically not really acknowledging a lot
of criticisms and they eventually that will wear you down especially
if you are offensive to people in a way where they're happy to
see you fall. I think eventually that will wear you down if you
have a lot of people who like outright hate you.
Especially if you're pretty egotistical, which it seems like
Nick is. I don't know. I don't know. I I tend to think that if
you have like this problem being like a total schizobarian, like
Destiny has this problem big time, but Destiny will go and like
fight with people and try to win those arguments, right? And
I think that's how he keeps moving forward. I don't know if Nick
I don't know. Maybe he is maybe he will just block his way out
of like these spheres and it'll be totally fine. And maybe
possibly >> until he showed me pictures of them >> No,
no, no, no. He's not just going to be an H3 cheerleader. He's
going to do other stuff, right? Like he's covering this stuff.
There's I mean the Caleb Hammer stuff might be a little bit related
to H3 as well. He's got an Ana docket here as well.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure, sure, sure. Sure.
I
how do I put it? I think
he'll just do stuff in a way that's not going to require any
responses. He's going to become like a streamer version of, you
know, the sensitive society type of people. He'll keep doing
the same thing. He'll do anti-Hassan stuff until, you know, the
wheels fall off.
That's I think that's basically how it'll be.
Now,
speaking of anti-Hassan content or pro-Hassan content, depending
on how you look at it, I think after this, I'm going to switch
over to whatever that Pisco stream was. We'll maybe watch a little
bit of that. Apparently, Pisco is watching some Hassan comment,
some
clips, and basically going like, "Yeah, I think I agree with
this." Yeah, I think I agree with that. I I don't know. I think
it'd be pretty funny. Oh, I had a song clip in my for today,
too. Whatever he was talking about guitar
We might have to check that out in just a little bit. On one
occasion, he did drive to my place and rant about Kai for like
3 hours before having with me. That was aggressive. That is when
he showed me text from her and told me about the blackmail folder.
I did ask him if it was okay to film a couple of times and made
jokes about the meta goggles, but the rest of the times he would
start filming without asking. A couple of times I waved my hands
to get him to stop and express discomfort and he did stop but
kept the videos. I believe I held the phone up once during one
of the times I asked him to film. There were several occasions
in which he would take his phone out amid sexual activity and
record without asking first. I also find it interesting he called
me an insecure partner. when another girl came forward confirming
that he was indeed cheating on me throughout our relationship.
>> Nick, do you have any friends left? Yes, dude. Vega
is Well, Vega is not not funny, so I'm not going to mention him
right now. Auggie, Willie, and and
they all hate each other, actually. So, it's it's pretty fun.
It's pretty fun.
>> Wait, why would Tom hate anyone else in that group?
Wait, why? Hold on. Why would Tom hate anyone or anyone hate
Tom in that group? What did Tom do to that group that they hate?
Oh, Tommy C. Oh, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. Tommy C,
Tommy C., which is another thing we should probably do. Hold
on. >> I don't know. I just kind of make content. That's
what I I just I just >> and do other [__] when
I'm offline. >> Another thing, >> dude. All my friends
hate each other. It's so fun. >> He didn't address is the
age play situation. The woman he met up with has been exposed
multiple times for being an age player and agon. That was one
of the main reasons for me coming forward in the first place
because she dressed like a child and fed into that stuff. Based
on what I've seen from our Instagram, there is absolutely no
way he would not have known this. He also did not address the
comments he made towards me and Katie about us looking underage,
which were genuine comments he made. The things I said in the
interview about a Destiny and Dick Masterson were true. And he
told, "Dude, I saw a comment. Is it going to get shown here?
I don't know if he No, he doesn't show it. Someone said, "Did
Tom did Tom do Coke with Dick Masterson or not?" And and she
they responded back and they said with her track record she probably
did coke with master sin and that killed me. That literally mauled
me at like 2 in the >> for hating me without my consents
which he conveniently left out. Mr. Frost replies by saying like
bro we have her >> and by the way I don't think that she
did coke with master sit on the grounds that I don't think she
ever has ever been to California. So just to be clear for any
legal entities >> times calling it time and him saying
stop saying that is she delusional. Not only that, she even is
not denying the text are fake. She even basically said the is
untrue without saying it. Not only that, she told Tom to watch
Lolita. She is lying in real time. Also, isn't it convenient
she is now? Yeah. Wait, that's so Holy. Wait, I'm sorry. Can
we just go back? I forgot about this. So, she said the Lolita
poster is not from her room, but then just doesn't address the
part where she said you need to watch Lolita. I forgot that was
in there. Dude, I'm literally getting by this girl in real time.
>> More proof. She's like, "You need to watch Lolita right
now." [laughter] >> And not when she was smearing him.
Is she a warlock? Is somebody >> I for did anybody else
completely forget that until Mr. Frost said it? >> More
evidence when it's necessary and >> She told him to watch
the movie. Yeah. Tom's response is I don't think that men should
watch that. And her response is like it's for the girls
on Nicholas
>> appreciated the shout out. >> I forgot. >> That's
my tweets. Holy. >> Yo, there you are, bro. [laughter]
>> Cried goddamn now. Also, also she is now saying that
the age play had to have happened because the woman does age
play. This is disgusting behavior. It's like saying, "Oh, you
[__] that because she does only fans for work." Like,
were you there in the bedroom when they
What? It's my tweets. Holy [__]
This is from Winter Balls 2000. I'm assuming these ones. Or is
there a tweet from Winter Balls? Nope. It's this guy. She told
Tom to watch Lolita. She's lying in real time. Okay,
hold on. Also, also she is now saying that age the age play had
to have happened because the woman does age play.
Okay, that's a weird argument. I do think there's like something
to finding somebody who does age play is like a thing they do
for their entire brand as an influencer and then going to hook
up with them. But anyway, that is disgusting behavior. It's like
saying, "Oh, you that because she does only fans for work." What?
What? I don't understand the comment.
What is the What is the comment? What What is the point that
they're making?
Oh, you that because she does only fans for work like they're
in the bedroom and they I actually don't understand
what like the first one is, oh, you this woman because she does
age play.
Okay. Like, but the second one doesn't have a negative connotation.
Yeah. I'm sure a lot of people if you found somebody who did
Only Fans, you found somebody through their Only Fans like connected
account, I'm sure you're them because that part of you their
backstory like intrigues you in some way.
Yeah, I would make that assumption. Is that a weird assumption
to make? I I don't feel like that's a weird assumption to make
at all. [__] that because she does Only Fans. You're
watching a girl who has like a specialty. Okay. She's She's a
throat goat on Only Fans. I have a feeling you're going to ask
that girl for a You know what I'm saying? You know what I'm saying?
When she's got a reputation, she does something very very well.
I feel like that might be involved. I feel like it's not weird
to say I think that might be involved.
Is that crazy work? Like were you there in the bedroom when they
Zaf Ruiny also post this post by Sacramento on the our YouTube
drama subreddit? And big bang banger replies. See this here is
why Kiwi Farms is the worst place to drop accusations against
people. The fact that not only is she now saying it's consensual,
but all the negative ratings she's getting makes it clear this
is >> that's an interesting raid. Thanks
>> Just some petty reven. >> I'm sure that you enjoyed
that previous segment plot. Tom ain't clean. >> Yeah, crazy
right >> either. But at this point I would be behind him
more than either.
>> These women unless it wasn't consensual with Left 4
Dead and I feel now I have no problem with that. Dickers can
raid Nicholas. I don't even care if Dickers is friends with Nicholas.
Okay,
but that's a that's a rough one to come out in the middle of
um
Yeah, that's a that's a rough one. Some people are not going
to be happy about that. Some people are going to be like
this Dickers guy to be fair. It's probably not going to be people
who didn't already dislike Dickers, but that's a tough one Sacramento
here until Ideal replies on this sub. I noticed Kiwi Farms is
simultaneously most credible place and least credible place on
the planet for information. depending if the sub likes you or
not. In the OG thread, they took everything as gospel because
Tom is an ass hat with very questionable ethics and character.
Lil J says the big issue is that 4 days before posting to KF,
she called him to black. >> I mean, yeah, dude, the lying
about the date as well is absolutely insane. We broke up in December
cuz she knew it looked bad if she broke up 4 days >> Chip
suddenly his doesn't work anymore. There are parts where she
says it's so big it hurts, but at the same time he can't get
hard and has ED. Just so you know, rough does not cure ED. She
contradicts herself too much to be anywhere near reliable and
she has destroyed any trust in her story. Katie saying she realized
that she was a victim after >> also she's saying that Tom's
isn't big but she spent like an entire 4hour interview and multiple
like and then yeah wrote about it at like 3:00 in the morning
saying how big it actually was. So can we really take anything
that she says seriously >> for the second trip while at
the same time planning a third trip across the country is also
a red flag. The whole thing comes off as he didn't want to sleep
with him anymore. So to them the relationship became an issue.
Also, posting a KF because you're scared he is going to leak
the videos and immediately leaking stuff to null is a bad look.
I'm pretty sure the only reason we don't have the videos is because
she didn't >> Oh, earlier this month. Okay, so not December.
Earlier this month, implying >> Okay, I think we we've
probably got nothing else here. Maybe I'll try to go find the
uh the Pisco stream. See if we can find anything there. Oh, Nicholas
is
You can't make it up. You can't make it up. You can't make it
up. You probably can't see it because of the chat. Am I right?
Yeah, you can't see. Oh, you can kind of see the icon here. Hold
on.
You guys see it? Do you guys see it? You guys see it? Very funny.
Very funny. Hold on. Maybe I should make it bigger. One second.
One second. One second. Can this go over? Thank you. Boom. It's
a girl with a microphone. Okay, go now. Let's go now.
Oh my god. Girl with a The girl with a microphone. >> Danger
is my middle name.
>> How does this guy How Okay. How does he do it? How does
he do it? How does he swap outfits so quickly?
How does he get the wig on that quick between streams?
It's insane.
This is a talent never before seen.
It's It's crazy.
I don't know how he does it.
>> Absolutely wild. She is not streaming anymore though.
The Prestige. Okay. Oh